j'ai toujours regretté depuis ma
naissance de n'avoir pas été le premier
bébé au monde a parlé
il raconte la vie d'un homme un écrivain
de sa naissance à sa mort un homme
passionné par les mots tous les maux
sont prêts à venir manger la quiétude
d'un romancier ou de tout écrire en
général soit parce que très souvent
l'écrivain cherche un mot ils ne
trouvent pas toujours se méfier des mots
qui arrivent à toute allure qui vous a
plu ou sur votre langue souvent sont pas
sont des mots un petit peu des mac
hulluch au secours les moments manger
est au départ un ouvrage bernard six
journalistes animateurs lui aussi un
homme de lettres
le mét aujourd'hui en scène avec un peu
de lui même
j'aime les mots tout simplement parce
que ils sont et ils ont occupé une
grande place dans ma jeunesse dans mon
enfance ma mère je peux dire mais
surtout parce que je trouve que les gens
ne font pas assez attention aux mots
vivants nuit et jour avec des monstres
non ce que nous entendons que nous
lisons et malheureusement nous c'est un
peu comme l'air qu'on respire on ne fait
pas attention à eux une nouvelle
déclaration d'amour pour la langue
française partager avec le public
un one man show à savourer sans craindre
l'indigestion
je n'arrivais pas à les garder à les
retenir comme eux en chiffres eux n'est
condescendance libations alors je notais
sur un petit carnet à trois sous
japonais parker mais comme les biquettes
il n'en faisait qu'à leur tête et il
s'échappait